national border patrol council vice
president art del coyo joins me now
art what do you think mayor adams new
york city calling on texas to provide
migrants housing instead of busing them
out of state
it's it's frustrating to see and it's
frustrating to hear people call out
governor abbott and i'm going to tell
you why
because he's the one governor out there
that's actually doing something to try
to take care of the problem when
everyone else is turning a bland eye
we got individuals in washington that
have not even bothered to go down and
see the problems that all these
individuals are facing we're talking
about the people that live there we're
talking about the law enforcement
officers that are out there working i
just left one of the processing centers
and i was talking to some of the agents
there and they're frustrated they're
frustrated that we have these large
groups of individuals coming across from
all over the world
some of them are not carrying any
documentation
they're not carrying any passports no
identification whatsoever you got to
take their word for what they tell you
their name is and where they're from
a lot of them are using the same name
over and over and they're getting
released in the united states that is
what a lot of these lawmakers they ask
for that's what a lot of these
individuals that are in cities that are
sanctuary cities that's what they asked
for now they're seeing the reality
instead of calling out governor abbott
they need to be calling out the
individuals that have something to do
with it like this administration that
have done nothing about it yeah that's
what they need to be calling i mean you
have these folks though who are saying
open borders are fantastic that's what
america is all about read the plaque on
the statue of liberty uh you know and
and
and so
the buses show up and all of a sudden
they're like hey what's this all about
well this is what you want this is what
you're advocating this is your ideal of
america except when it comes to you
footing the bill except when it comes to
your citizens being perhaps threatened i
mean the hypocrisy is so rotten it's
amazing it's it's almost hard to fathom
that mayor adams would make such a
comment that somehow texas should
provide housing for folks who enter this
country illegally
you you know what it is is you have a
lot of these politicians that are a
thousand miles away they're like the
like the internet gangsters they hide
behind keyboards and like to post what
they think this should be done they're a
thousand miles away they think they know
what to do but then when they're faced
with the hard reality of what really is
happening oh and now i don't know what
to do well you probably should have
figured out what to do before you opened
your mouth about what you think people
should be doing now they're faced with
the reality now it's time for them to do
something about it themselves call out
the individuals that are actually have
caused this pandemic the individuals
that have caused this crisis at the
border and it's this administration
that's what they need to be calling out
not somebody like governor abbott that's
actually doing something about it you
know all right i mean listen i i know
these politicians are mostly wedded to
their beliefs on both sides of the aisle
and it's rare they ever have an epiphany
but this seems like that moment you know
president obama talked about a teachable
moment this feels like one of those
moments maybe you have an epiphany and
say now i see what my fellow americans
are going through let's rethink this
maybe let's finish the wall and start
talking about some real policies so that
we can control who comes into our
country with the greatest nation in the
world we know why people want to live
here and we we welcome immigrants right
that's what we are it's who we are in
our core but we want to control the
situation don't we
i'm an immigrant myself and i can tell
you right now my family was vetted
correctly before they came here and
that's all we're asking i've said it a
thousand times before and i will
continue saying it look when you come to
my home you got to knock on my door and
i make the decision whether i allow you
in to come inside my house you can't
just be climbing in my windows whenever
you want all right at least if i do show
up unannounced i'll bring a bottle of
wine or something all right thank you
very very much i really appreciate it
listen i know you've gone through a lot
man and we appreciate you we really do
thanks a lot
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now